then you ask yourself well what's the
limit of that because that's the
religious question fundamentally is
well if you took on all the
responsibility you could take on
and you faced everything that you needed
to face
what would you be like who would you be
and how would the world transform around
you and
well if if the partial answer is well if
i do that a little bit things get a fair
bit better then the next question might
be well
what if you did that completely
and i don't think that's possible in
some sense right it's like
you know perfection is a horizon that
always recedes but it isn't obvious to
me
what the upper limit of that is and
certainly we do see people i mean saints
see it's a [ __ ]
it's a francis of israel who kind of
pushed the limit and
they
miraculous things happen around them
maybe in the literal sense and if not in
the literal sense close enough you know
for all intents and purposes and
so that's heartening
i now welcome to our stage our own
president father dave pavanka tor
[Applause]
[Applause]
father dave became president of
franciscan university of steubenville in
2019
the first franciscan alumnus to lead the
university
father dave also earned a master of
divinity
an m.a in theology a doctorate in
education an executive juris doctorate
he is a member of the most sacred heart
of jesus province of the franciscan
third order regular he was ordained a
priest in 1996 a well-known catholic
speaker an author father david has
written seven books and produced several
evangelistic films and video series
including sign of contradiction metanoia
and letters to myself from the end of
the world through the ministry of the
wild goose please welcome father dave
and our speaker dr peterson
[Applause]
well thank you so much and again i'm
just very pleased that the turnout and
everybody being able to join us this
evening
as dr peterson and i were talking this
morning one of the things that he was
mentioning was that he often doesn't
come to universities anymore
for many reasons
and we asked him well then why did you
accept our invitation and his response
was because you seem different
i hope that was a compliment
[Applause]
and it's been a blessing to have dr
peterson with us he's been so generous
with his time all morning spending time
joining us and seeing our campus joining
us for liturgy so it's been a great
blessing and honor to have you with us
so thank you so much thanks very much
for the invitation
so i appreciated dr peterson's
discussion on the corpus of of the
scripture of the bible in in the book
and one of the things that he and i had
talked about was to discuss
a book
not the book
fair enough
definitely
so when i was
praying and discerning about which uh
chapter i wanted to talk about what i
thought was most appropriate there were
a few things that were going through my
mind
on monday we're starting
the holiest week of the year for us
we're entering in a holy week which is a
time that invites the church and the
people of god
to look at the cross that is ultimately
going to lead us to the cross and
and how suffering is so central to the
christian experience and christian
redemption comes about through suffering
so there was that that i was continuing
to think about but i was also pleased
lord reflecting on the fact that
we're near the end of the podem the
pandemic
and one of the things that i've been
praying about over the last many weeks
and months is how the pandemic has
placed in forefront of our culture
suffering
and death in pain
and it seems to me that we have not
dealt with that very well we've got to
the place where so many people are
riddled in fear as if
suffering is to be
run away from at every cost at every
opportunity the idea that there actually
could be something beautiful and holy
and salvific about suffering
so when i was reading through your book
and i saw in the last chapter
you speak about suffering and being able
to do that with a sense of gratitude
i just felt that that was the place that
maybe we could talk about this evening
and what does that look like
the very beginning of the chapter you
say
a much of your life you have been
searching for certainty
and then you pivot very quickly to speak
about suffering so maybe two questions
your search for certainty
how has that brought you to what you
spoke about earlier this evening
and why did you make such a quick pivot
to talk about suffering
well i think it's because
the
if you're looking for certainty
the reality of suffering is certain
i mean
what do you accept as evidence above all
else
that's a good question that's a hard
question but i would say pain is up
there
it's very difficult not to believe in
the reality of your own pain
um it's somewhat easier not to believe
in the reality of other people's pain
that's not so easy either you know
but it's
your pain seems to be
undeniably real
and so
it does beg a question which is you know
if pain is undeniably real is that which
overcomes pain even more real
and i think that's in some sense that's
the idea that lurks
behind the idea of the resurrection
i mean i was going to
tell a story
during this lecture
today although there wasn't really a
place for it but maybe this is a good
place for it i'll tell you something
else i've been thinking about
which really
knocked me for a loop let's say which i
probably still haven't really recovered
from so a long while back i had planned
to do a
series on exodus i did a biblical series
on genesis which
people seem to appreciate which i found
extremely useful um it was
quite a
privilege
to have the time and the space to walk
through those books and try to
understand them
first psychologically and
i like to speak about things
psychologically
before i would ever dare to speak about
them religiously
i think you leave that for last resort
in some sense
um
i was thinking about some of the ideas
that
i talked about today um
you know about the bible being
the foundation of the lens through which
we look at the world we have this idea
that the bible is a living text
and you know if we embody it then it's a
living text that's actually accurate and
i
i think
to the degree that we're
avatars of the judeo-christian tradition
that we do embody it for better for
worse and we're stuck with that or
blessed by it or both
the reason i didn't tell you the story
was because i didn't know how to weave
it into
the theme that i was developing tonight
but it's relevant to the theme of
suffering and what might the reality of
suffering and perhaps what might be more
real than suffering
so i'll tell you the story hopefully i
can do this reasonably briefly
in the in when when moses is leading the
israelites through the desert
i'm very compelled by that story you
know
so for example one of the things that's
really interesting about it is that
the story begins with a tyrannical state
and then
it's the spirit of god that
leads the hebrews
maybe it's the spirit of god that
characterizes the hebrew
longing for freedom and that's kind of
an interesting idea you know
psychologically you think that
what's the spirit of god
the spirit of god is that which
manifests itself within you in
opposition to tyranny
could be you know that's
that's not a bad
idea it's quite an idea it's a
remarkable idea
and maybe it's true
it's certainly the case that that's how
god is presented in that story
and in many other ways but but that
being paramount
uh above all
and you know there's a there's another
corollary to that which is well we
shouldn't be subjects of tyranny if
we're children of god for israel and
israel means we who struggle with god
it's not
appropriate for us to be
subject to tyranny
that's interesting too because i think
we we
we sort of accept that idea at face
value in the west is that yeah slavery
is wrong obviously it's like it's not so
bloody obvious these things you know one
of the things that i'm really curious
about in relationship to the most modern
types who make group membership the
science
of existence is why is slavery wrong
exactly it's like it's just one for all
groups and one group lords it over
another it's like that's not wrong it's
just tough luck for the
for the oppressed group it's there's no
wrong there because it's only wrong if
we're sovereign individuals
right with some intrinsic worth who are
not to be subject to arbitrary tyranny
that's when it's wrong and you have to
accept all those other
axioms
before you get to say anything about
slavery being wrong at all otherwise
it's just hey like marx pointed out it's
just brute economics
and so you can make a moral judgment
about that if you want but
what's your criteria for saying that
it's wrong you know and of course that
would upset people
on the radical left who want to presume
that it's intrinsically wrong without
having to presume all the things that
you have to presume to make it
intrinsically wrong and without even
noticing that that's just a sleight of
hand in any case so that's part of that
biblical narrative too we're not the
sorts of creatures who should be subject
to tyranny and then the tyranny might be
well is it the tyranny of a state or is
it the tyranny we impose on ourselves
and i would say probably both why not
both the story could be referring to
both we tyrannize ourselves with our own
presuppositions all the time
and then you might ask yourself
why why don't we just give up our
tyrannical presuppositions
you know because they're not worthy and
they're oppressive but we don't give
them up and we often celebrate them and
i think the story has an answer for that
too because it's out of the tyranny
into the desert
it's like is that better or worse
how about worse
and so what if it's the case that even
to escape from the tyranny of your own
presuppositions that you don't go from
the tyranny to the promised land you go
from the tyranny
to the desert
and who the hell excuse me wants to do
that
and the answer is no one with any sense
it's like hey i'll just keep the tyranny
thank you very much at least i know
where everything belongs there
and
fair enough i mean this is a very
serious question and it's it's an open
question in the exodus narrative whether
the desert is worse or better than the
tyranny
and so and you know you see this in in
the real world lots of people in the
soviet union pined for the days of
stalin
so i read a book once that was uh
reminiscences of a
of a of um extermination camp written by
the guards
the good old days
you know so i don't think there's a
tyranny that's so brute that we can't
long for it if it's been shattered
and so that's quite something all that
packed up in that story anyways so the
israelites are out in the desert
and uh
they're there for 40 years and you might
think well what kind of leadership do
they have it's not that big a desert and
the answer is yeah but you know the
desert after a tyranny that's no bloody
joke and maybe it takes three
generations to get through it
and that's possible and so
there's all that and then the israelites
are wandering around in the desert what
happens well the same thing happened to
them as it's happening to us they're
worshiping false idols and they're
tempted and it's no wonder they're
tempted because
while they're in the desert it's like
it's not going so well it's no wonder
they're having a crisis of confidence
you know
and and maybe they're pining for the old
days and they're not so sure that the
god who informed them that being the
subjects of tyranny was wrong because
now here we are in the desert and so
they
lack faith
and
it's understandable
but despite it being understandable and
this is one of the harsh things about
the story
what does god do when he hears their
complaints
he sends poisonous snakes in there to
bite them i think that's pretty brutal
you know and that's the sort of thing
that make it makes the technical atheist
type sort of recoil about the
conceptions of god in the old testament
like it's not exactly what you'd expect
in some sense from an all-merciful being
it's like you've got these poor
israelites
first of all they were in the tyranny
then they had that part go across the
red sea now they mean wandering around
in the desert and that's not
good and so your best solution is to
send a bunch of snakes in to bite them
but you think well you know even if
you're in the desert after a tyranny and
you lose faith then the snakes are going
to bite you
right because that's what happens
because
if you're in
you know a little
analog of hell
and you lose your faith is that going to
make it worse or better
and the answer is well i have reason to
lose my faith it's like fair enough that
isn't the question
the question is what happens if you lose
it
or you start looking for faith in the
wrong directions and the answer is
hell gets a little deeper
that's one of the things that really
frightened me i spent a lot of time
studying atrocity and one of i realized
on a metaphorical level that the reason
hell is a bottomless pit is because no
matter how bad it is there is some
bloody stupid thing you can do that will
make it worse
and that's right you know and that's
terr that's a terrifying realization to
really understand that and so
okay poisonous snakes and so now the
israelites are not only lost but they're
being bitten
by venomous creatures and you know
there's an echo of the snake in the
garden of eden in that story and
um
and so finally the israelites they get
kind of tired of being bitten by the
snakes
and they go to moses and say you want to
have a chat with god because you seem to
be in there fairly tight with him how
about you get him to call off the snakes
and maybe we'll
behave a little better how's that for a
deal and moses says okay i'll see what i
can do and he goes and has a chat with
god which is no trivial matter and god
doesn't do what you'd expect because
what you'd expect like and this would
even work
in terms of making it a comprehensible
narrative you'd think okay
all right guys
you've been bit enough
no more snakes
but that isn't what happens
and i think the reason that it doesn't
happen is because there's no getting rid
of the snakes i think that's
that's also why there's a snake in the
garden of eden is there's just no
getting rid of the snakes
you have to learn to contend with them
it's more like it's more that or maybe
it's better to learn to contend with
snakes
than it is to inhabit a world where
there's no danger maybe it's something
like that i don't know
anyways
god says something extremely surprising
and very interesting from the
perspective of a clinical psychologist
he tells moses to cast snake in bronze
and to raise it up on a staff and the
staff seems to me to be a reference to
the staff of moses and that staff of
moses is something like the thing you
put in the ground to orient yourself
with it's the staff of god too and it's
sort of like an axiom and maybe it's
like the tree of life it's it's it's
it's it's like here i stand it's a
center point it's all of that in any
case you put the snake up on the staff
that's also the symbol of healing right
the physician symbol of healing the
staff with the snakes and so it is a
symbol of transformation and partly
that's because snakes shed their skin
and are reborn and so they're viewed as
agents of transformation and so that's
all lurking in that symbol
and then god says get the israelites to
go look at the snake on the staff and
then the poison won't poison them
anymore
and i read that as a clinician i thought
that's really interesting because one of
the things that we learned
all schools of psychotherapy learned in
the last 100 years is that if you get
people to voluntarily confront what
makes them afraid and what makes them
want to avoid then they get better it's
curative
and so that's the message there it's
like well if if something is terrifying
you
pay more attention to it
and that's actually what you teach
people in psychotherapy i mean there's a
variety of psychotherapeutic techniques
but exposure is probably
the
the cardinal technique
it's like if i can find out what you're
avoiding
and get you to confront it voluntarily
you'll get better and the reason seems
to be is that if you get people to
confront what they're afraid of and
sometimes what disgusts them but what
they'd like to avoid let's say if you
get them to confront it voluntarily that
could be the future even you know the
indeterminate future
they don't get less afraid
they get braver
and that's different it's not like they
get accustomed to what they're looking
at and they're no longer afraid that
kind of happens but it isn't really what
happens what really happens is they
discover there's a lot more to them than
they thought
and so they're not as easily intimidated
then and so if you run a clinical client
through a session of exposure therapy
maybe they're afraid of an elevator or
something like that you get them so
they'll go in the elevator and sometimes
they're often women because women have
anxiety disorders more often than men
one of the unintended consequences of
that often is they'll go home and have
the fight with their husband that's been
brewing for 30 years
because they're now braver they see
themselves in a different light because
they've confronted this thing that
terrifies them and so it's so
interesting in that story that god's
cure for this for the venomous serpent
is
voluntary exposure to the source of
terror it's so interesting that that's
the case
but that
and this is relevant to the issue of
suffering right and confronting
suffering dead on to actually
focus your attention on that which you
would like to avoid
one of the remarkable parts of that
story is also that
one of the scariest words ever is if i
was god they wouldn't have been bitten
in the first place right so they put the
they've got the serpent the serpent's on
the pole but they're still going to get
bit and i think that that's what's
essential about that is just because the
serpent is there doesn't mean that
everything is fixed it now looks like
they're still there
but the the transformation that takes
place is the focus of the suffering
becomes a symbol of faith for them and
that's obviously on the cross well and
part of the faith is the faith that
enables them to go look at the serpent
to begin with absolutely okay so that
leads us to the next part which is in
john because christ says thousands of
years later that he has to be lifted up
like the serpent in the wilderness it's
like okay
what in the world is going on there
because that's a hell of a thing for
anyone to say about anything ever and
it's
right because what does that mean why
would the son of god compare himself to
a serpent and why that particular
serpent and that serpent in the
wilderness
and
i knew this old idea that lurks in all
sorts of stories in this corpus of
stories that i talked about you know
there's an idea that
the hero rescues his father from the
belly of the beast that's a very very
old idea and what that seems to mean to
some degree is that if you if you look
into the abyss
then that
what reacquaint it reacquaints you with
the wisdom and possibility of your
tradition it's something like that it
forces that
it forces a maturation and a recognition
of what's fundamentally important that
confrontation with what's terrifying
well
so christ says he has to be lifted up
like the serpent in the
wilderness
thought
what does that mean
i thought a lot about the relationship
between the serpent and the garden of
eden and the idea of satan because
there's an association there between
those two ideas and that's a very
strange association too because there's
nothing in the
in the biblical story in genesis that
indicates that the serpent is satan like
that's that's an idea that
aggregates across hundreds of years or
thousands of years that equation and i
tried to think that through i thought
well
the snake is the thing that threatens us
and that's true biologically um we're
wired to be afraid of serpents
especially poisonous ones and they've
been in an antagonistic relationship
with mammals for like 60 million years
very long time
but
in some sense the idea of satan is
he's the ultimate in serpents
and so that's why that equation is drawn
across time it's like well what
threatens you well snakes yeah they're
pretty nasty well
there's snakes and then there's well
the origin of snakes so maybe you
conquer a snake and that's one thing and
maybe the next thing is you go out and
you find nests of snakes and you root
them out but then there's the snakes
that are in the hearts of your enemies
that's a harder snake to deal with and
then there's the snake that's in your
heart and that's the hardest snake to
deal with right and that's where the
equation between the serpent and satan
comes because the worst of all snakes is
the serpent in your own heart
and so there's a there's a
psychologization of the idea of the
predator and it becomes something that's
more spiritual is that your most
vulnerable
to the worst impulses within you right
that's the worst predator
okay so there's the idea of the the
concretization of the idea of the
serpent becoming psychologized up into
this figure of the adversary himself and
that abides within you
analogously
perhaps
is this
reference that christ makes to himself
in relationship to the snake
is i thought well what's the passion
if the snake is what you're afraid of
in this concretized sense
then the passion
is the sum total of all possible fears
i think that's right you know carl jung
he thought about the story of the
passion as an archetypal tragedy
and here's what he meant by that so
imagine that you took all these
tragedies that were ever written
and you sort of
you distilled them so that you got the
ultimate tragedy because the fact that
you can identify a bunch of different
stories as tragic means they have
something in common right and so you
could imagine you could pull out the
central pattern of tragedy and we could
flesh out some of what that might be
like it's tragic when something bad
happens to someone
well what if they deserve it
okay well then it's not so tragic it
still might have an element of tragedy
but it's really tragic if something
really terrible happens to someone who
clearly doesn't deserve it
so what's the most tragic story
well it's the worst possible thing
happening to the person who least
deserves it well that's core to the
passion story that's for sure right
because not only is christ innocent
he's not merely innocent he's also good
and not just good he's as good as it
gets and yet his life is
this
the tragic
the tragedy of the passion is the worst
of all possible punishments
visited upon the least deserving person
but it's much way worse than that that
just barely begins to scrape the surface
because
it's
torture
and a terrible torture because the
romans designed crucifixion to be a
terrible torture like consciously
and so
it's tragedy at the hands of your fellow
man
and your fellow man motivated by the
spirit of cain in the most fundamental
sense how can i inflict the most misery
possible in the shortest period of time
let's say subject to that at a young age
with foreknowledge as a consequence of
betrayal by your best friend at the
hands of a mob
of your own people
who are simultaneously under the thumb
of a tyranny that's part and parcel of
what's persecuting you who persecute you
knowing you're innocent not just
innocent but also good and who
choose to punish you instead of
punishing someone they know to be
criminal
it's all of that it's like the sum total
of all possible fears and i think that's
right and it's so interesting to me that
psychologically that
not speaking religiously to the degree
that that's possible when speaking about
such things is that
our culture has put at its center
an archetypal tragedy
it's as if we're
attempting to inoculate ourselves
against the catastrophe of life
and but what's
also so fascinating about the story of
the passion is that
the crucifixion is not the end of the
story the end of the story is the
resurrection and so the implication
there is the same as the implication
of
going into the abyss to rescue your
father from the belly of the beast it's
like
the tragedy isn't the end of the story
the resurrection is the end of the story
and so then you wonder what that means
psychologically because what you see in
psychotherapeutic session
in the psychotherapeutic milieu is that
if you get people to expose themselves
to what they're terrified of
being terrified isn't the end of the
story
recovering is the end of the story
and so that begs the question is like
well to what degree are we capable of
bearing suffering and prevailing and the
answer might be
to the degree that we're capable of
confronting it forthrightly
and that might actually just be true
and you know you think well
how could it be otherwise in some sense
like what's going to call the best out
of you if it isn't the most what's most
challenging
because it's not that easy to get the
best called out of you it's not going to
just happen because someone rings your
doorbell right you have to be shook to
the core before you're going to
undertake what's necessary to make the
sacrifices that are required to put you
in
alignment that's
that doesn't happen with no reason
so
well so
are you grateful for your suffering as a
consequence of that
i don't know that's a high standard man
that's a high standard and and maybe
it's unrealistic but but i think one one
of the things that that
faith brings us to is and we were
talking about it when we're in the in
the chapel in the friary is that when we
look at the cross and it's it's
very catholic
is that we always see jesus there that
the corpus is there and because you talk
about in the in your chapter but what
does it look like to transcend suffering
and what does that individual look like
and in some ways our our businesses are
similar right people are bringing their
brokenness to you and they bring their
broke brokenness to me
but i believe in a god that that can
transform that so i was asking myself
what does that look like and
and i recall a priest that i met in
africa and i believe what he had was lou
gehrig's disease so by the time i met
him he was no longer
able to really move his arms or legs
very well we were praying that the lord
would heal him in that
and then he began to share his story
with me in what had taken place in he
and his community in the midst of his
sickness in the midst of his suffering
was he said people didn't used to go to
church very much but since i've been
sick people are coming
and that they wouldn't line up for
confessions but since i've been sick
there's a long line of people coming to
confession
he said the church was half full and now
it's packed
he said people begin to speak and they
say that i'm more empathetic that i'm
more compassionate that i'm more loving
but i'm more kind
and i'm embarrassed to admit that at
that moment as he was sharing his story
about the transformation that was taken
both in he
and in the community i was praying lord
please don't heal him
because
if we believe that
that this is what i want to be right i
want to be loving and i want to be kind
and i want to be generous and i want to
be empathetic but i don't want it to be
through the cross there's got to be
another way that we can discover that so
wouldn't it though right but the
fundamental key to the central christian
reality is it's through that cross
that we are transformed it's it's by one
things i was reflecting on jesus
embraces his cross his suffering and
says yes to that a yes which
i i just can't remember he says yes to
it too yes yes she offers that's the
question that i want to talk about is
which is more difficult for he does hey
good question thank you i'd rather just
a second good question thank you very
much i think we're done thank you for
coming
right
but but but isn't that isn't that in
fact the case is that when jesus
embraced his suffering he gives life to
the world he breaks the power of this
evil one over the snake and gives life
suffering is no longer meaning
meaningless actually it's salvific but
the same thing happened with this priest
in this community in in nairobi africa
is that he embraced the suffering and it
transformed him yes but it also
transformed the community around him
because they saw the way in the manner
with which he's he suffered and he
embraced that and he found that to be
transformative isn't that what it means
when you talk about transcending this
and you talk about how the impact that
that can have on another person watching
that's that's what the invitation that's
what the gospel is inviting us
to yeah that seems right to me okay so
how do you reconcile this thank you what
another reconciliation
so so you tell the story and you tell
the story beautifully of the past and
the resurrection but
how do you how do you personally
approach that how do you reconcile this
reality i think that's what you try to
do in your life
you know i mean
this is an idea that
that i derived i would say in large part
from reading you
carl jung
he talked about psychologically again
about the two great ideas
about christ you know there's the idea
in john and
that christ is the word that was there
at the beginning of time and at the end
of time it's this
temporally
eternal
divine word
impersonal in some sense almost um
well because it's something that extends
from the beginning of time to the end of
time isn't so evidently human you know
it's it it's it's elevated beyond the
confines of what's merely human but it
lacks something as a consequence of that
too right it lacks time and place
and the way christianity the nature of
the incarnation yeah exactly exactly it
bridges that gap i had a student once
who asked me why don't we just tell the
same archetypal story over and over
why do we need all these variations and
i thought that's a really good question
i'm not exactly sure about that
and then i thought oh it's related to
this issue is that
there's the divine word but there's the
incarnation and the incarnation
indicates that the specifics of time and
place are just as important as the
eterna as the eternal that surrounds it
and so then i would say well that's
probably true in each of our lives is
that well how do we reconcile this and
well that's your that's your ethical
adventure how you reconcile that and we
each do it in our own way and with
tremendous difficulty i would say and we
do it aided and abetted if we're
fortunate by people that love and care
for us
but that is the challenge you know a
huge part of the challenge of life
and this is something i tried to
concentrate on in this last chapter is
how do you bear
the suffering that
is at the crux of life
without becoming tempted and embittered
that's really really difficult now you
know someone might point out
go ahead and be bitter see where that
gets you and if you have any sense and
generally people have at least some they
know that
being sick and bitter is worse than just
being sick and that being right it's
worse
but it's very hard temptation to avoid
sometimes you want to be bitter just out
of spite
in some sense because things are so
terrible
all you've got left is your willingness
to shake your fist you know and say well
you know really is this like
this many poisonous snakes really
that's like maybe i could have learned
with just one or two not a hundred
and so
but we're stuck we're all stuck with
that and i think we're stuck with it at
every level of our life in some sense is
how do we maintain a
high order moral orientation in spite of
suffering and malevolence yeah when i
was a young seminarian um one of the
things that i started i worked in a
neonatal intensive care in this summer i
baptized over 20 babies and all the
babies died and it was very
i was a seminary and i was supposed to
have all the answers right and they come
to me and they say you know tell me real
quick why did this happen you know this
this guy why did he allow this to happen
and i came to the place a couple things
one is that i didn't have to i didn't
have to defend god like in my own mind
in my own heart there was something very
freeing in that i don't know why i mean
what kind of explanation let me explain
to you why this happened oh well thank
you so much yeah that makes sense i wish
somebody would have told me that right
right but what i did but what i would
continually come to is that
and this is a mystery of the faith that
jesus is present in the midst of the
suffering
and i i tell the story actually the
first book i wrote was on freedom and i
spent a lot of time in that exodus text
because that's
the the invitation to look at pharaoh
and be freed and that but
that that when we're children and we
fall down and we scrape our knee our mom
comes and she kisses us and she passed
us on the head and said it's gonna be
okay
and it is i mean really what has she
done she's she's kissed me on the head
she's petting me she said it's gonna be
okay
but we grow up and we don't think that's
enough anymore
but my experience tells me is that when
when christ can do that for me
in the midst of my brokenness in the
midst of my suffering in the midst of my
pain and remind me that i'm loved right
i remember sitting in the chapel it was
a thursday evening as a seminary and
trying to figure all this out and
hearing the lord breaking in the midst
of that and say dave i love you and i
said well i appreciate that but that's
not the issue let me explain the issue
what am i supposed to tell these people
and he reminds me that i'm loved and
and it's enough
it's enough
and that's that it's the christian
mystery of suffering that it ought not
be something that we try to escape but
it's actually an invitation that we
continually find jesus because i suggest
that when we find god in the presence of
the suffering we can find him anywhere
it's it's easy to find him in a sunset
or in a baptism take a a brand new baby
pour oil all over them and grease them
up and it's smells the chrism it's
wonderful it's easy to find him in that
how about about cancer
yeah and divorce
and infertility
that when we can find and that it's the
mystery of our faith that god enters the
messiness rather than just fixing it
from the outside he enters this and and
takes this upon himself
and transforms it when we find him there
i suggest we find him anywhere it's my
experience is that our faith becomes
more real it becomes more authentic it
becomes more
present
when when we can find him in the midst
of that
yeah well that that
what would i say about that
well i guess one of the things i would
say about that is that
perhaps
it looks like
you know we have something difficult to
do
as it turns out you know we might think
and
why wouldn't we that we would rather
that things were easy and pain-free and
fair enough
but
that isn't
what our life is like
it's extremely difficult
it's difficult to maintain
an ethical orientation in the midst of
malevolence and suffering
and that means
in some sense and i suppose this is part
and parcel of the christian story that
we have some divine calling
it's something like that it's like
and that divine calling is to
establish what's good in the midst of
what isn't
to be jesus in the midst of it to be
christ yeah well that's because that's
that that's the question i i guess i i
i don't know exactly what to make of
that because i don't know
to what degree
we're called on to
find christ in the middle of that let's
say
or to be lifted up like that in the
middle of that i think he's both hand is
yeah
fair enough i think so the christ i mean
to the degree and this is i think
if i can't and this is hard if i can't
find christ in me
then i can't find him in them
and if i don't see what what he's done
how he's alive in me then it's as a
priest or as a believer it's hard for me
to invite somebody else to that and it's
hard for me to to see him in somebody
else so that's where after first paul
says that as christ was alive in me
when i experienced that not just not
just read it it's not just a
corpus that we look at that we read the
bible but it's a lie it's a living word
when that becomes alive in me
then it allows me to be able to see that
in other people because because they
know me well
i can find him in me because i know it
goes in this head well and you see you
know when you see people who are noble
in spite of their suffering it is
ennobling it is uplifting like really it
is and
um and it's been striking to me too
people want to be encouraged in that
direction i mean
part of the reason that my lectures i
would say have been successful to the
degree that they have been is because
people find them encouraging
and that actually seems to
work like it seems to be positive
because it isn't good news well it seems
to be i mean it isn't necessarily the
case that that would be the case you
know because it could have been that i
would have said encouraging things to
people there's more to you than meets
the eye and you're capable of more than
you're demanding of yourself and you
know if you took on your responsibility
and faced the things that you're trying
to avoid that your life would be
richer and better and for you and for
everyone around you and the result of
that could have been that thousands of
people would come to me and say you know
i gave that a pretty good shot and it
your advice is really awful and
everything is well seriously like i took
on that responsibility it just bloody
crushed me and i'm way worse off than i
was before and everything's gone to hell
around me and like thanks a lot buddy
and
that and that it's not like that's a
completely
incomprehensible possibility but that
doesn't seem to be what happens is what
generally happens is that young people
in particular but not only come to me
and say
look i've been trying to take on more
responsibility and to face the things
i've been avoiding and everything is way
better it's like okay well
isn't that something to something well
then you ask yourself well what's the
limit of that because that's the
religious question fundamentally is
well if you took on all the
responsibility you could take on and you
faced everything that you needed to face
what would you be like who would you be
and how would the world transform around
you and
well if if the partial answer is well if
i do that a little bit things get a fair
bit better then the next question might
be well
what if you did that completely
and i don't think that's possible in
some sense right it's like
you know perfection is a horizon that
always recedes but it isn't obvious to
me
what the upper limit of that is and
certainly we do see people i mean saints
let's say you say it's a [ __ ]
it's a francis who kind of pushed the
limit and
they
miraculous things happen around them
maybe in the literal sense and if not in
the literal sense close enough you know
for all intents and purposes and
so that's heartening i mean i
tear myself apart about this in many
ways because i think
perhaps it's possible to take on too
much responsibility and to crush
yourself as a consequence maybe that's a
sin of pride who knows it's certainly
possible
but
my experience so far has been that
when you see people bear their suffering
nobly
there's nothing in that but good
that's something and then when you see
people take on more responsibility and
decide that they're going to aim up and
and
confront their suffering honestly and
forthrightly that their lives get better
and the lives of people around them get
better too
and so it's that's very strange as well
because it also means that the pathway
to
less suffering
is through suffering
right and that's kind of that would be
hopeful if the world was constituted
that way it's like while they're
suffering how do you make it worse run
away
how do you make it better confront it
yeah but it's suffering it's like yeah
but it's there there it is it's right
there it's a precondition for existence
or something like that and it's like you
have something important to do as well
and you confront it and that's the
pathway to transcending it
probably
it's rough
maybe we wish it would be different and
maybe we don't too
yeah when i was reflecting on
parts of your chapter one of the things
i was reflecting on in in light of also
the snake right well i think a good
suggestion is not to have a conversation
with the serpent all things being equal
but
he he ultimately they believe the lie
right and i think isn't one of the
greatest lies of the culture of the evil
one i would say i find it really
interesting
you use the word the adversary in satan
which from a psychologist and a
scientist
in this morning you said yeah you meant
that that there is an evil there is a
personification of evil if you read
if you read
anything about
auschwitz about
the nazi death camps about what happened
in the soviet union
if you read that sort of thing seriously
or if you read about people who've done
like i read a lot of
books about
the worst serial killers
and i mean
that's quite the competition
and to be the worst serial killer which
people do compete for by the way
um it's not like the high school
shooters don't know about the
reputations of all the other high school
shooters it's not like they don't try to
outdo them because they certainly do and
they do it consciously
i mean if you read those
accounts and you don't walk away with
the notion that evil exists and that the
notion of an adversary is like as real
as it gets then you just haven't read
very carefully how do your peers deal
with that when you say they don't
you know i mean psychologists generally
don't mean some psychology clinical
psychologists talk about evil
but
but non-clinicians tend not to and
that's because they're just never they
just
aren't confronted by it you are if
you're a clinician i mean you see things
in families that are so terrible that
they're
inexpressible and multi-generational
often you know and the only language
that you can really fit that sort of
thing in is a religious language
it's that's the only language that's
serious enough and you know people
i don't know the idea of evil is taboo
idea scientifically it's like have it
your way you know one of the things that
solzhenitsyn
claimed was that the nuremberg judgments
were the most significant ethical event
of the 20th century or at least among
them because
the nuremberg judgment was that some
things are
wrong
right you don't get
the excuse i was following orders you
don't get the excuse that's how my
culture looks at it do you don't get any
excuses that's what a crime against
humanity is it's like do you believe in
crimes against humanity
the answer is either yes or no because
those are the two answers and if it's no
it's then okay
you have the world where that's the
belief and see how that goes and i'll
have the world where i think that there
are things that are evil and we'll see
how that goes
and because
you're going to not
condemn
the imposition of
pointless suffering on people for the
sake of the suffering that's not
wrong in some fundamental and
transcendental sense i mean you can say
no
you know say i don't believe in evil
it's okay but that has its consequences
and one of the consequences is you can't
condemn evil
that's a problem
you know or maybe not
but
it's not like a world where you don't
condemn evil it isn't like there aren't
consequences to that decision
you know and i also think that there's
no good where there's no evil
right and so if you dispense with the
idea of evil
don't you simultaneously dispense with
the idea of good i mean because
if something
doesn't exist how does its opposite
exist
and if evil doesn't exist then how does
good exist because in some sense those
two things are they're
integrally linked in their reality
one of them only can't exist right it's
that isn't how things work if if there
wasn't something that wasn't good there
couldn't be good and maybe that's the
reason there's evil you know
metaphysically speaking because you
might ask yourself well why would god
make a world that's characterized by
evil and the answer is well maybe evil
can exist as a possibility but not a
reality it could if we did things right
evil could exist as a possibility and
not a reality maybe to that end
augustine says i quote that i wrote it
says preparing god would not allow any
evil to exist unless out of it he could
draw a greater good this is the part of
the wisdom and the goodness of god and
as the believer we see that ultimately
in the crucifixion of jesus that
we call good friday it's there's this
craziness that we call it good friday
and the darkest day of human history but
it's good right that that day is good
because of the salvation that comes
about from that but
to be able to make that step honestly i
think my suspicion is a lot of people
that come and see you as a psychologist
is because they're not able to reconcile
that they're not able to figure out
that there is actually a good and an
evil and those two things ought to be
recognized and seen
yeah well it's a it's it's it's very
difficult to reconcile especially if you
you know one of the things you do that
does happen to you as a clinician and no
doubt as a priest is that
you you see people often people who are
often people are shattered
not because their life is tragic
although that does happen but because
they've been touched by malevolence
like tragedy in and of itself isn't
enough
you know you can bear a fair bit of
tragedy but if if someone had it in for
you
and you know you were betrayed and your
life was blown into pieces because of
the voluntary betrayal of someone who
was aiming at your destruction and you
think well that doesn't happen it's like
yeah well you better wake up because if
you're asleep like that it could easily
happen to you and i wouldn't recommend
it because it happens to people all the
time and sometimes they do it to
themselves
and that's that's brutal i recall the
story of one of our graduates she was a
nurse and
she was just a bathing a patient and her
head nurse and was kind of watching her
and
she pulled her aside a couple of days
later and she said i've watched the way
you treat the patients
you treat them differently she said
there's a tenderness about you and in an
ability to see the person there's just
something different in your chaster
what do you attribute this
and she said i suppose two things i've
suffered greatly and this was a young
woman that i'd walked with and
has known horrible abuse within her
family which is just such a violation
but she said i've suffered greatly and
then she said and i've been loved
greatly
and and it was interesting that that her
her colleague could see that that there
was something different about that and
she attributed to ultimately suffering
and ultimately to be like yeah well that
does it does seem it can catalyze a kind
of maturity that would be evidenced in
that sort of
that sort of interaction we could
probably go on for a while but we're
time a parting thought
oh i guess perhaps
i guess i'm hoping that uh perhaps that
you catholic types stop being so
apologetic for your virtues amen
you know one of the things that the
radicals are really good at is
weaponizing guilt
and good people have a proclivity for
guilt you know because if someone
accuses you of something especially if
multiple people accuse you and you're
a well socialized person a conscientious
person you're going to tear yourself
into pieces pretty hard trying to figure
out if they've got a point and that's
fine you know fair enough
but it makes you vulnerable to
to
another
satanic synonym is the accuser
right this question is well how
susceptible should you be to accusations
and that's a tough one because like i
said if you're a good person it's pretty
easy to feel guilty but the problem with
that is is your guilt can be weaponized
and that's definitely happening
so all of you people with your privilege
so
you know i i guess i'd part with that
thought
i think part of the reason
that there's an injunction a religious
injunction
to a tone
is to come to terms with your privilege
so that it can't be weaponized maybe
it's me it's more complicated than that
it's a good start it's like there are
all sorts of advantages you have that
other people don't have and no doubt
disadvantages as well right that are
unique to you but let's stick with the
advantages it's like well what makes you
deserving of those advantages and it
can't really be historical happenstance
you happen to be born american you know
which is relatively good fortune because
you can really not attribute that to you
you know what you don't deserve that in
any sense
um
so how do you justify it and i think the
answer is
by leading an ethical life
like that's actually the answer it's not
like you should lead an ethical life
you should that's not the issue
the issue is that's how you atone for
your unearned privilege and the
advantage to that is
you can't your guilt can't be weaponized
under those conditions not by other
people which is very important at the
moment but also by you
it's like you think well i've got these
advantages well what am i doing about
them i'm doing the best i can with them
right that's how i justify them as i try
to treat them as gifts and i try to make
the most out of them in a way that's
maximum beneficial for me and for
everybody else simultaneously i'm
actually trying to do that
it's like well
who could ask for more than that
and i think that's
well that's one
weapon
in the culture war
it's like if you're living an ethical
life
you know if you're doing your best
well maybe you can stop apologizing for
your privilege and
maybe that would take one weapon away
from the people who want to burn
everything down because they definitely
want to burn everything down
so
i invite the coral if you guys want to
come up and get set uh we're going to
have a closing hand
just to that end though one of the
things that that you and i talked about
and i think it's important about the
university is that the goal for our
students is just that you know it's it's
to be able to
go out into a world and
be holy and be a saint and ultimately i
think that that's what the world needs
is
is men and women that are going to live
courageously i loved how in this chapter
you spoke so often times about
courageously well
this is hard it's hard to live this life
it's hard to be faithful it's hard to be
good it's hard to be right and yet it's
the challenge that i think our student
body has accepted the call that the lord
has on their life to be yeah well i
think that's the basis of any real
education is that you know it's a call
to nobility
it's a call to virtue
fundamentally
because what good is education if it's
not a call to virtue
so so i also asked uh
dr if he would mind if we prayed with
him before uh through the evening his
wife wasn't able to join us but you're
certainly welcome anytime
i offered him a job earlier and he
didn't say no
he didn't say no but
but um
i
i must say
i must say in many of our conversations
today some of the things that we're
doing here and some of the things that
you're working on i think there's a
great synergy and a great way that we
can collaborate so i look forward to oh
wouldn't that be good this is a
collaboration i suppose john paul is
going to come up and i just invite you
if you want to just what why don't you
stand and you stay you remain seated and
we're just going to invite the
congregation to stand
we're just going to ask the lord's
blessing upon dr peterson and also his
wife and his son and daughter that the
lord would continue to pour his
blessings upon them and john paul is
just going to lead us in a song just a
very simple song of blessing so we ask
the lord to bless you dr peterson
[Music]
and keep you
please face shine upon you
creatures too
lord
[Music]
heavenly father i thank you for bringing
our brother to us today
i ask your blessing to be upon he and
his wife his son and his daughter
let them continue to know your love and
your peace your healing
father i pray your your protection upon
his work
continue to inspire him give him courage
give him strength
that his mother teresa remind us we are
but a pencil in the hand of god
and that you would continue to plot your
blessing that he would write well
fill him with your grace your presence
in the midst of his own suffering may he
discover and find you there
may lord brought his blessings upon you
dr peterson god who is father son and
holy spirit amen thank you very much for
joining thank you very much thank you
all
thank you everyone much appreciated
thank you
thank you